art vingt ans après l amérique rend
hommage aux 3000 morts du 11 septembre
l'attentât le plus meurtrier de
l'histoire américaine et qui a impacté
le monde entier ce matin-là quatre
avions ont été détournés par des
terroristes d'al qaïda deux d'entre eux
se sont écrasés sur les tours jumelles
du world trade center un mémorial il a
été construit depuis et c'est ici que la
cérémonie officielle a eu lieu thomas
bonnet notre correspondant aux états
unis a suivi cet hommage pour nous
thomas bonjour alors l'ambiance était
très lourde cet après midi on imagine
parfaitement une atmosphère particulière
oui l'heure était à la commémoration aux
hommages pour les personnes qui ont
perdu la vie pour les héros aussi qui
ont aidé justement à sauver des vies le
jour du 11 septembre 2001 alors il ya eu
donc cette cérémonie d'hommage qui a
démarré assez tôt ici aux alentours de 8
heures heure locale et il ya eu
plusieurs moments forts des moments de
recueillement des minutes de silence qui
ont été observés et puis les noms des
quelques trois mille victimes du 11
septembre ont été lus par justement des
familles des victimes et cela s'est
achevée il ya assez peu de temps
finalement parce qu'évidemment il ya eu
beaucoup de noms qui ont donc été cité
lors de cette cérémonie et puis beaucoup
de gens ont décidé de venir aussi
assisté à cet hommage ou en tout cas à
se rendre à proximité de ground zero pas
très loin de là où nous sommes c'est
juste derrière moi il ya beaucoup
d'américains qui ont fait le choix
justement de venir pour des raisons
parfois très différentes certains
préféré rendre hommage à une partie des
héros par exemple qui ont aidé à sauver
bien des vies lors de ces attentats on a
aussi élu par exemple des personnes
rhône hommage aux pompiers on a aussi
beaucoup vu de famille qui justement se
rendait à cette cérémonie puisque vous
le savez cette cérémonie était réservé
justement aux familles des victimes
elles arboraient un ruban bleu ciel et
parfois elle avait aussi des cadres mes
portraits parfois même des t-shirts à
l'effigié et bien des êtres chers
qu'elles ont perdu le jour des attentats
du 11 septembre et puis quelques
messages politiques aussi arboré par
certains américains
mon retour évidemment de la guerre en
afghanistan mais en tout cas le son de
cloche était assez unanimes d'abord
rendre hommage à ceux qui ont perdu
perdu la vie et puis transmettre aux
nouvelles générations et bien le choc
qu'a représenté cette attaque ces
attaques contre les états unis il ya
maintenant 20 ans alors thomas des
commémorations qui ont été également
l'occasion d'attaquer le président biden
oui beaucoup de critiques autour de ces
commémorations un contexte très
particulier pour le président américain
d'une part parce qu'il y a donc eh bien
cette crise en afghanistan ce retrait
chaotique des troupes américaines il est
la cible de très nombreuses critiques
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines des
critiques y compris de la part de
familles de victimes du 11 septembre je
pense notamment à la soeur d'un des
pilotes d'un des avions qui a été
détourné il ya 20 ans qui s'est montré
très critique sur les différentes
antennes américaines où elle a été
interrogée ces derniers jours beaucoup
de critiques dont contre joe biden est
évidemment celui qui s'est montré le
plus dur peut-être aujourd'hui c'est
donald trump qui est vous le savez n'a
pas participé à ces commémorations il y
avait trois présidents en exercice deux
anciens président joe biden barack obama
bill clinton les trois présidents
démocrates des états unis met donc pas
de donald trump ni de george w bush qui
lui était au mémorial pour le vol est
bien 93 et donc donald trump a lui
publié un message vidéo où il a d'abord
rendu hommage aux forces de l'ordre aux
pompiers qui ont servi il ya 20 ans mais
aussi et surtout pour critiquer très
vivement joe biden je propose d'écouter
le leader de notre pays et passer pour
un idiot et cela n'aurait jamais dû se
produire c'est le résultat d'une
mauvaise planification d'une faiblesse
incroyable et de leaders qui n'ont rien
compris à ce qui se passait c'est le 20e
anniversaire de cette guerre et cela
aurait dû être l'année de la victoire de
l'honneur de la force au lieu de cela
joe biden et son administration inapte
on transformer cela en défaite
son cloche totalement différent de la
part de kamala harris et de george
w.bush qui ont eux appelé à l'unité même
fait part de leurs craintes quant à la
désunion qui guette les états unis
évidemment en référence aux différents
débats aux différentes controverses qui
ont eu lieu ces derniers mois propose là
aussi de les écouter
dans les semaines et les mois qui ont
suivi les attentats du 11 septembre
j'étais fier de diriger un peuple
impressionnant résilient et une si on
parle de l'unité de l'amérique c'est
ensemble lointain une forme maligne sans
dieu à l'oeuvre dans notre vie
quotidienne qui transforme chaque
désaccord en dispute et chaque dispute
en choc des cultures une grande partie
de notre politique est devenue un appel
brut à la colère à la peur et à la
rancoeur cela nous rend inquiet pour
notre nation et notre avenir commun
après le 11 septembre nous avons pu voir
comment la peur peut être utilisé pour
semer la division dans notre nation
lorsque des américains sic et musulmans
ont été pris pour cible en raison de
leur apparence et leur culte
mais nous avons également vu ce qui se
passe lorsque tant d'américains dans
l'esprit de notre nation se sont montrés
solidaires de tous les sommets de leurs
concitoyens de ceux qui subissent la
violence et la discrimination
voilà donc pour les appels à l'unité de
george w bush et de kamala harris qui
tranche évidemment avec le discours de
donald trump en tout cas donc un
contexte particulier autour de joe biden
cible de critiques pour ces
commémorations et qui on rappelle a
perdu une grande part de sa cote de
popularité depuis maintenant plusieurs
semaines merci beaucoup thomas pour
toutes ces précisions thomas abonnés en
direct de new york